what we're going to do is go through the
Tyree Nichols beading or incident
we've got video I want to warn everybody
and I'll try to remember to do this
throughout we're going to be showing not
just the Nickels case but other cases
that are pretty rough going so if you
know people should be forewarned about
that first we're going to see him being
pulled over we can discuss what happened
there and then we'll move on to the
actual uh beating that occurred I didn't
do anything
all right all right all right all right
get on the ground
all right I'm on the ground
um
I'm not doing it
freak
oh [__]
from the point of view of somebody who
has uh you know prosecuted police but
and also worked with police departments
and other forms of law enforcement in
order to kind of make things better what
are your first you know what what is
going on in that scene that is most
important for people to understand I
spent many years either as a police
auditor or An Inspector General
reviewing incidents just like this and I
would say that when you see exhibited
there in the first two uh minutes is
extraordinarily stupid policing uh lack
of discipline a lack of exhibiting any
effort at the escalation or what often
police officers will say is taking
control of the scene so what you're
seeing is immediately the officers start
escalating you know guns are drawn
yelling contradictory commands I'm not
explaining what they're doing there you
know if you see
um a well train unit which is doing what
they would consider a high risk stop and
let's assume for a second the officers
thought for some reason this was a high
risk stop even though they claim is this
for reckless driving so I have to assume
this is what they do all the time their
tactics are off the charts horrible some
other officers met up with him as he uh
fled to a nearby neighborhood that
apparently
um you know was was near where his
mother's house may have been but um
these I've spliced together two
different a few different angles here
one is from a
um a Lamppost so it's a high angle shot
and then you see some of the same uh off
the officers body cams
so here's the high angle shot you can
see them on the ground
um they're again trying to
subdue him that you've seen officer this
is after they've caught up to him after
he ran yes they caught up with him an
officer has a baton out and now he's
beating him with a baton
so yeah hold them
yeah go ahead Walter so you're seeing
you've seen this baton strikes they seem
to be pretty on focused
again a lack of poor tactics lack of
control so what uh sadly Mr Nichols ran
into smack dab as compliance culture
he wasn't complying so you know they
take that as an affront because from
what I can say and they kept on up in
the ending yeah well and we'll see
that's that same scene there from a
different angle now
um and with some sound
[Applause]
shut the [__] up hey come here
you might get spray it again
mom
get your hands give me okay all right
all right
all right okay so basically now
all right give me your hands
you're saying he's complying that
essentially at this point when he says
all right his hands are going behind his
back now he he is complying so I think
that a lot of officers you know let's
assume everything that just happened
before with a really poor tactics and an
unnecessary escalation and inflammatory
language that none of that has happened
and you have somebody who is ostensibly
uh has presented some resistance he's
saying all right now and they have
control of his hands
that's right
all right
oh [__]
you guys give me a [__]
where the [__] it is
I think this is really important with
the body One camera footages show often
you're saying why do officers use force
and they use Force because they have a
reasonable belief in the threat to
themselves or a threat to others or
they're trying to seek compliance
depending what the threat is that's
presented depends about how much force
should be used now this officer whose
body were on camera we just showed
obviously did not think it was that
urgent because he had completely stepped
back to the who that vehicle he was
taking a break cutting now what he was
thinking and then he decides to
re-engage does he re-engage because
there's some sort of an ongoing threat
that he now has to control or is it
re-engaging because he now he wants to
go in and get some licks so again you're
showing a complete breakdown uh in what
policing should be
give us your hands
give us your ass same location
for most people including myself that
looks like a beating of a at some point
helpless and relatively defenseless guy
to the point of unconsciousness and as
you mentioned they're they they keep
yelling do this with your hands let me
see your hands even though it seems like
they had him some under control these
guys know that they're wearing body
cameras why would they do this knowing
that it's all on camera I'm gonna
speculate here for a second okay and
this and the speculation is that when
you have officers who in engage in
excessive force and violations of the
Fourth Amendment on a regular basis
they are essentially wrong the dice
every single time that it is not going
to go too far to get too much attention
these types of officers
except for the really dumb ones I'm not
sure which category these guys fall into
those types of sadistic officers they
know where the boundaries are this last
clip I want to play from the incident is
the aftermath so it's when Tyree Nichols
is you know they kind of pushed him up
against the car he's just slouching over
there and they're all talking through
what they think just happened or what
maybe they want to say just happened
okay
come on
I'll just note right there that there
was one of one of the officers there
saying remember your your camera is on
uh bro
sit up man
uh
[Music]
I eat it
bro
we're taking his camera off
editing him with Haymakers
almost hit me
he literally had his hand on my gun like
yeah so we tried to I'm talking about
yeah he didn't stop we still instead of
trying to get himself he decided that
might drove around swear like he
couldn't hit my car so then I'm like God
damn what are we doing he pulled up to
the red like stop at the rear like put
his turn signal on so we can jump out
the car
she went from there I think the two
clips are are important for how they
showed really two different phenomenon
going on uh the first was
um that immediate aftermath when
probably the cameras should not have
been on from their perspective
uh and you heard incredibly
unprofessional language and attitudes
being exhibited you know these guys were
just in the fight I mean these are all
big guys too right and uh Mr Nichols was
not a big guy and so just goes again to
show how incompetent their tactics were
that if they actually were trying to
deal with a combative person who he was
not uh that how Porter tactics were but
everything they were talking about you
know Haymakers and this and that show
this uh you know just admissions of
violence uh the second clip though is
that is was for the camera right and you
heard basically the one officer kind of
walking through the narrative where
everyone else could hear it and so my
guess would be if there was a subsequent
administrative's interview you would
hear pretty much everyone reflecting
that now I've not looked at for example
The Narrative from the police report
that was filed that night but my
suspicion is that if you listen to what
you just heard that one officer
explained there you're going to see a
pretty close narrative that was written
down when people think there are these
conscious efforts to collude to make a
false statement would you just saw it
seemed really benign and almost natural
where they don't even recognize that
that is what they're actually doing
that's an excerpt from our reason live
stream that Zack wise Mueller and I do
every Thursday at 1 pm we were talking
about Tyree Nichols and the Memphis
Police and what can be done to fix that
with Walter Katz of Arnold Ventures if
you found that interesting please look
in the description of this video and
click on the whole discussion thanks for
watching